okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are back again for another
look at calculus and algebra
functionality in the next version of
Wolff language so where have we got - we
were looking at these are open that in
12 X kernel right
whew and there was some you know just
don't open graphics actually at least
yesterday it crashed different yeah
right
okay all right do we have so I think
Jeremy is here too yes
is he yeah I'm here okay
so we're looking for a design for these
creatures okay so
do you really think okay so I've got so
let me just explain meta a little bit of
reasoning and behind it so these are
different than summary blurbs which are
very big sort of you expect one per line
or or something like that these will be
nestled into expressions yeah these root
objects but now so each one of these if
we ask what is it right if you if you
look at the tooltip it'll show you what
the old input form was or actually still
is okay okay right so that's what this
is representing okay right and it's
doing it in a more useful way because
it's saying the approximate numerical
value exactly and you see one of the
things there those three dots indicates
it's an infinite number you're just
seeing the initial saying I'm not
convinced aremy might not know that I
yeah right but I'm not convinced about
that I don't think that that's right
because you know what when we when we
have you know when we say this
yeah that's an infinite number as well
but we just say you can't get any more
number it's given that number you can't
get anything more that's it you have to
have that has to be around pi then
dispersed why is the Elysian I say it's
a difference that is a finite truncated
number okay we got a bunch of loud sound
I think when you're on Roger
okay so the first problem here is that
that square root thing um makes it look
like it's the square root of this so
that's clearly wrong um and I don't know
I mean is that square root thing really
the right I mean we could just say root
we could say the word root small Roger
I wanted something visual and I don't
think saying roots does that that's
right didn't go that route there is
something else which we can't do now
because the tail is too long to figure
out so we can demo it so we have
something else that's called numerical
approximation then I will take anything
numeric you a sorry exact number I think
yeah and it will take anything that's
numeric you and call s it into a symbol
like this germs
where you get the numerical
approximation okay let me let me look at
what about scientific notation cases
what's happening with those here
I mean you'll you'll get those what is
it so I mean if I do that if I say root
you know hash 1-10 to the you know 50th
completely contain we evaluate it make
it exact that make it agree at least
three so that it doesn't simplify
okay alright so that's gonna get a
little bit wild and funky when it's a
when it's a complex number isn't it is
it gonna have separate it's gonna have
separate things for each real imaginary
part right oh well it'll it'll share the
exponent I'm pretty sure right so I
think I mean it'll do whatever number
form does right so if you do just
multiply that by something that's
probably won't sure that's funny because
it can be a different scale on the
margin arrogant now right so those guys
you know how do I get it coincide yeah I
don't think it has any choice but to do
that you're right okay all right so what
you're describing is that there's
there's a an arbitrary approximate
number thing and what's the closest to
this in terms of for example quantities
or you know I'm saying well this is the
way I think pi is sort of the closest to
it right it's a it's a represent or
square root of two on some level right
this is and that I'm asking in terms of
typesetting right so what we do here is
it's white it has slightly different
color and has a mouse-over so here what
we're trying to do is to represent an
exact number I mean in this gray
background thing what else do we have
that is kind of like grey background we
have time objects we indeed objects to
take a look at those okay so it's a time
object but say let's just say 3:00 p.m.
I was really ugly in formatting that's a
can we come over we're back do I need to
report that somebody should tell Nick
that that's really a miss formatting
okay what's the problem oh three is
wrong okay do I need to tell that to
Nick I'll tell that to Nick okay so in
any case um okay so that's a case where
we have a background I mean I have to
say I'm not that wild about these things
I think they're rather heavy I like
those I think that they give you a sense
of what the heck is going on
at a glance well depends where you're
seeing them you know if you see a table
of ten of these it's a bit heavy it I
agree yeah I mean it's also the case
that just like with images we could in
principle have a form of these that are
ylides more I mean just like if we have
a you know if we do random image you
know 5050 or something whoops so if I do
that and then I do table of that comma
10 oh that's surprising maybe they maybe
these are already small I'm surprised
those didn't get smaller
well a graphics does that I'm not sure
that's true those must not be small I
mean those must already be small enough
for something okay so any case it does
that and so on so we could imagine
something with these somewhat heavier
forms that lighten up when they go in in
lists and so on
okay so let's come back to this so this
is a darker gray which you don't really
understand and the point is this is a
number and what Roger is saying is that
it's going to be future numeric
approximation type things that work for
arbitrary exact numbers right um so okay
so we have to invent something right and
so one question we have to ask is right
so basically I think all I've
implemented this route but of course
right there's also algebraic number and
we have various representations of you
know a way to represent an exact number
and to what extent do we do we want to
you know tell you which representation
you're using right that little radical
there is to tell you you're using a root
representation as opposed to well what I
can't be for an algebraic number I think
it should be the same really missed a
both algebraic number they're just
different heads doesn't matter okay so
what's another example right I mean are
you imagining that if there's a giant
rational number that it could be
represented in this way too we weren't
actually so what's an example so some
radical expression yeah or or just sort
of you know when you shold
transcendental problems like integration
and differential equations and
difference equations and some you get a
lot of numbers out there are sort of
instances of special functions and other
things in pies and E's and all of these
things I don't think we want to alight
those I think we do because state they
will then show the structure of the big
thing that's a different thing
yeah common sub-expressions and so on I
think that's a different problem of it
it's not common sub-expression this is
and it's a more involved discussion okay
so one there there are a so there are
some functions that actually care about
the structure of numbers as
we've gone through and for instance made
sure that they are aware of this new
represented this is for 12 one not for
12 that I'm talking about now mm-hmm and
they also combine like like roots do not
okay and it allows for a lot more
clarity in the resulting formulas a lot
more insight immediately okay Roger I
think that that's in the category of
things like code folding
I mean it's look that is similar to I
can eyes I mean you could say the same
thing about a big block of code but I
think that that initially people were
very kind of proud of the fact that they
could generate long formulas I think we
now view it as noise I think people
still like it so I'm not I'm not there
yet so I mean and by the way I hope for
12 oh that we're doing better than this
list they might we've redone these
haven't we Jeremy there's there's a
proposal it's blocking on me actually to
review it so we had some iterations and
Billy sent me a up three did draft a
couple of weeks ago and they just
haven't had time to look at it so I mean
this won't happen before I see em but
it'll happen before release no the
artifice even we don't intend this this
other exact number to be automatic it
will be generated by some functions but
but generally speaking you have to
explicitly do it yourself
so like that mechanism I'd never seen
that before the UH nikon eyes mechanism
there did you see that
that's new yes it's nice it's very nice
um I think that - is a little coarse
looking and certainly bit and this this
whole baby that's not let's not waste
time on this there's a new proposal
coming that will show you and I had this
conversation before okay alright okay so
in any case there's some kind of
approximate number form that will be
similar to this form which happens to be
route generated mm-hmm okay this one is
simpler from all the sort of
infrastructure support point of view
because it's just a type saying I
understand but the point about it is
that you're gonna need an iconic form
that represents this is an exact number
but I'm only showing you the approximate
version of it
yes that's what you're right yeah this
is one where the structure of that
number happens to be root or algebraic
number related then it could also be a
transcendental root it's good yes right
and so one question was well but they're
all roots you know there are roots
although one question is you know do we
want the sort of group algebraic number
and algebraic roots with one icon and
then you know transcendental roots with
no no I don't think
okay look okay Jeremy we need an idea
here so first of all I think the dot
thoughts will be helped by being gray um
because the dot dot is really not that
important it's just you know truth in
advertising so to speak if I made sense
that's true yes um and the real problem
is first of all you know do we this gray
background what is it supposed to remind
ourselves well it's supposed to remind
us of like things closest thing okay but
I mean the other thing that it is
somewhat close to his icon eyes
right that it's also I believe the same
gray used by by summary boxes right
Sophie too sparse array of one two three
and so simplest um it's actually not the
same guy you're right okay it should be
I mean we can write and you're certain I
see you're keen to have something which
is a small object like that root sign
rather than the word root yes because
you're gonna have many of these in a
formula I understand all right okay
Jeremy how do we maybe you could mark
something up but how do we deal with the
problem of this looking like a square
root there what I'm saying I'm working
on that I think the shape of it actually
might help a little bit let me show you
what I have I mean I I don't know what
to do with the other version of this
that you know not I think we need to
discuss that once we get to the further
we can demo and because there's this we
still working through scenarios more
global how are you sending this to me
Jeremy I can just mail it or do you want
to show rather mailing okay but the
thing
Paige should have it yeah I thought
about that as well
I think the circle helping a lot
actually and the smaller ones nice I I
don't know that we need the blue the
gray was it's there and marks it but you
know you can't see the blue through
through the next session but it I like
the circles Jeremy it's nice yeah I
think to me it it doesn't flow in as
well it's more obvious it's a separate
type of information but yeah I think it
works so like this one here is fortunate
proposed yeah I like that one the
smallest yeah yeah I like that one too I
hey you know I don't know how to create
that icon myself or I might have tried
to UM okay did that lighten up did you
lighten up the gray background there or
not I I didn't I lightened up the dot
but I didn't like the gray yeah it'll be
a federal effect and the font size is
being inherited from the outside right I
think so
they can't swear to that they have to
look at it okay I think those dots
should go even smaller and lighter okay
we find with that next week
just in particular to avoid the big
space before the eye and things like
this there because the majority of these
things I don't know we could probably
figure out some mathematical argument
for what fraction of these things will
be complex numbers but it's a very large
fraction right yeah and we are sure that
we need dots on both the real and
imaginary parts yes we're sure about
that but sure we can't have some other
way of okay so I'm going to make a
different possible argument okay what
about the possibility of having a tilde
tilde before the thing
well they're having dot dots at all so
have something like this approximate
yeah we we prototype that we decidedly
like the dot that thought over let me
see if I still have that notebook
candies for you to see by the way if we
did that that would give us an immediate
way to deal with the other approximate
number thing and I think that you know I
would argue and Jeremy maybe you could
could help try and make this yeah put
that guy in a circle yeah let me and
then maybe somehow what's that that
could work
but then how do you get the root thing
and
it took after the routine there
especially if you do we are going to
extend it to arbitrary numeric things
I'm not certain that the route is a good
idea I mean I think the route may
actually be confusing rather than
especially since they're multiple
different things route algebraic number
etc let's try the lighter gray this
thing in a circle no dot dots then
people going to think it's approximate
numbers they're exact numbers it's a
huge difference
well why they think there's a big gray
blob there this doesn't say exact number
to me the dot dot dot does not say exact
number to me if you want to indicate
exact number yeah we should try it we
could try it how can we indicate an
exact number um well let's let Jeremy
try that okay well he's trying that
let's let's go on and discuss other
things we have to discuss here um can we
scroll down here the constant see thing
we talked about yesterday I think and I
think that's okay except that I strongly
think that should say see of one we
agree yes the till dual tip you mean
yeah yeah okay
should I look at one of these rough
pages you can do not have to bet you can
what is this - what the heck
this that's the number of examples that
have been removed from there oh yeah
they've bought from those to the correct
section I mean what is more appropriate
with the new design so things will just
open both from property relation to
scope so the point of this example
Steven they showcase we have a hell of a
lot more than just numerical evaluation
of special functions yes anybody can
build a numerical special functions
library these days and but we have much
richer support and this shows you the
tools and a support more like a handbook
of special functions let me see one of
these pages that's a pic I think you
want to go to the audio EDI perhaps this
is a good one no I'm gonna pick the one
I won't try to make Steven that's okay
no problem it's a losing battle so that
one is the fella
so now and under scope no this was a
assuming that this is another list we
have poured 50 of them you'd have 100 of
them so far my list is a little above
the this function domain and you need to
look at the list even that's all I said
yeah I know so I'm looking at okay fine
like you told me to all right thank you
yeah what what well this is I mean okay
it just feels like you know getting
something like this in there with
timings and so on it's very you know
before we're doing a lot of other stuff
in the scope thing just seems kind of
wrong it's numerical evaluation it's a
subsection no I understand one of the
key features a special function is their
ability to do high precision evaluation
no I am I agree but
that separator shouldn't be there yes it
should it will go away in the build okay
will go away in the build don't don't
take it out advice so touching anything
I'm not touching everything
beautiful I didn't know that's what the
error function looked like in complex
plane we don't for every function or in
this list of hundred and fifty more
coming for twelve point one then the
derivatives as well okay you know we
need some kind of well whatever I mean
it just it's kind of so ugly to have to
put that in there
and we could ionize it but I think that
would also be a mistake explain to me
the principle of this of this here I
mean so we have these different kids to
show you the you know so a little bit
like we did for distribution so a
distribution on its own is pretty
useless a special function is less it's
more useful on its own because it has
automatic numerical evaluation
properties but really what you need to
know is all the other functions that
operate and work with special functions
now I know to get this function domain
how to solve equations yeah all the
properties all these properties that you
need to get and learn about special
functions
yeah that's a lot of cool things there
so that shows that we have a much much
richer capability yeah I understand that
but I mean there's there's you can
actually learn something you know you
learn that there are three things that I
could imagine getting out of this okay
one is showing off all the cool stuff we
have another is becoming a handbook for
error AI and another is how do I do such
and such a thing
yeah to the point is you know most
people don't know about special function
it's a sort of a rare group that do yeah
I understand but I mean to me the I want
to know about this function we better
off in more of a computational essay
format we can have that too but you
you're in the system you better be able
to get the information there no no I
understand that I understand that but
I'm asking given what you have here
could it be refactored easily for a
computational essay that basically is a
little bit more narrative about what I
mean
you know we've we've tried to do these
function essays which I would say are
not particularly successful amount that
have been done for special functions
have they I don't know no not yet
okay well I mean my suggestion would be
and I've already said this that those
function essays be turned into
computational essays and here what I
could imagine with the area function is
you know a little bit of narrative that
says you know I don't know what it was
you know George Airy invented it and
studying the motion of the moon and it
shows up in a bunch of differential
equations of this type and then you know
those kinds of things and then here's a
plot of it and so I think this room for
that too but I don't think that takes
away from no I agree but I'm just saying
to you given all the work you've done
here could you simply refactor that
fairly easily as a computational assay
using essentially the same examples I
don't think so because you need to
actually add that history research the
application research and so on and this
is just scope sections
you know yeah I mean right clearly this
is not something which goes into the you
know the computational essay is unlikely
to talk about high precision air a
computation um I'm I'm certainly
confused by the way why this isn't area
of 1/2 n of area of 1/2 comma 500 it
could be well it's nice to see all this
detail I mean it's definitely nice to
expose all this stuff um
it's not complete it's one aspect of of
better promoting the special functions
and make them learn about and usable
yeah Turnus well it's great okay should
we go back to I just mail your statement
okay
it's hard to see what's hard to see the
tildes they are right now yeah
but I think that they're smaller dot dot
dots was a definite wind you know yeah I
made him as small as possible and still
kept them there they don't take up that
much space yeah they're not they're not
so bad yeah well the issue though the
tilde tilde is kind of incomprehensible
right and it's at least to me it's weird
to have tilde tilde n dot dot dot yeah
yeah that doesn't make sense I don't
think this is quite working but what are
we going to do for the general
approximate numbers well I kind of liked
your tilde I didn't think about that I
was thinking of n as a sort of you know
yeah well okay but so let's see if we
can make this work with tilde tilde
let's see if we can make this one work
which I don't think it quite does yet I
was thinking if you make that B blue
like that square root in the beginning
you can actually pick it out probably
just from contrast alone I think that's
the problem now
there's no Charlie you'll have to try
that um and
and yeah well I was going to suggest
reverse colors but that's probably too
heavy that's gonna be yes try it
yeah just makes little dots everywhere
it's a little too heavy that's what you
had in this thing here yeah okay
all right oh there are other things we
can discuss while we're I think we have
a meeting coming up right which we could
um yeah I don't know why we're actually
breaking this out of the generated
variables meeting has so it doesn't have
the same set of people in it um it's
coming up with the half-hour mark here
okay what else should we look at
anything else to look at here I think
you have covered everything now Steven
okay what about the selection so so your
proposal for 12 is to actually go to
default the output for route to be
displayed in this form is that correct
yes format for numerical routes right
obviously if there are parameters in
there there's nothing we can do so then
it will just be the route object again
exactly okay well I don't
I think this is quite nice um I think
it's definitely more useful than what we
had before is there any possibility that
the numerix could be hard to resolve or
is the numerix and stored in the
internal representation anyway it's
stored anyway okay you know that was
actually my very first question to Adam
will n ever fail me oh yeah
those colors don't come through it all
through the zoom session like I could
mail this out
I also think that this that that space
is too small I think it needs a little
bit more breathing room there okay um
some reason this is not quite doing it
for me
what would happen can you make the the
circle a little bigger so it's closer to
the edges of that the border of the
region
I started there but it was looking too
prominent may I say that that first
round there's a couple that have bigger
circles and I didn't seem that nice
like that one they you radio mouses yeah
well let's try I mean can we try that
Jerry just with the tilde tilde I mean
the problem is the tilde tilde is a
slightly more complex form than than the
square root we might have to tweak the
tilde so they have more waviness to them
which one were you pointing at
everything Photoshop this one here okay
yeah let me pull it up by the way I
think it's good that you're showing that
case with a minus sign there because I
think that case is worse than the case
with a number with a plus sign there
mm-hmm but we probably want to try both
cases
um okay all right while we're waiting
for that anything else we can look at
here I think we've covered everything at
this point okay right so we were oh
great
that will stack graphic yeah well anyway
okay all right for the next meeting by
the way we're talking about generated
parameters um I guess that's a bunch of
people that's not let's not do the intro
to that meeting yet all right should we
wait for Jeremy for a little while here
give me about three seconds okay okay
real-time graphics design yeah well it
makes the that's how come we actually
get these things done in reasonable time
if we were going back and forth with two
week you know turnaround and people
being confused about what was being
asked much site yeah these are for me
too actually
okay you should have it okay that's this
one
yeah yeah the next one over is it a
little bigger same thing same size
tilled us but the bigger circle and a
guy prefer the bigger circle okay
did you put the most space between the
circle in the beginning of the number Oh
pixel on the first one the other one I
did is there's a little more space on
the second one I just added a pixel to
the first one but it actually made a
difference so any other shape that you
can imagine a little nut circle rounded
rect maybe and like with big radius but
the rounded corners help since it's
inside of this rounded rect already yeah
I mean the fact is the only reason that
square root didn't work is because it
means you know it has a square root but
whereas this actually is supposed to be
red whereas this is not supposed to be
red square root of blah blah blah this
is supposed to be red approximately
equal to a blah blah blah yeah we could
get away with a rounded rect and it
would look just as good I don't think
the square would work okay
um I mean my other question is should
the should this be black because this is
kind of an ephemeral number and it
almost feels like if that was slightly
gray that would help distinguish this
from being what's really there so you
know because the communication is it's
approximately this kind of gloss number
so to speak
it's not you know that number is not the
whole story that number is just the you
know the representation the shadow of
what's really going on if you understand
what I'm saying right which suggests if
that shouldn't be black yeah I mean how
gray I mean it's it's it matters like
how gray it is so I agree I agree I mean
I'm wondering whether it could be
something where it's a little bit less
emphasized the box is a little bit less
emphasized but the grayness of the
number is more the story and it still
the tilde some stylized tilde tilde and
then a somewhat gray number
I even think it's possible that the
numbers should be down a font size from
the main you know from these main things
here because it's really
just an indicator number it's not you
know what's really there right me see if
I can't real quick somebody is asking on
the livestream that hope these images of
vector-based absolutely this is just us
some trying to mock it up the real thing
as absolutely vector-based will be
absolutely like - based without question
yeah and the the actual square root the
the current icon that I implemented is
in fact exactly a graphics expression so
it's you know look as beautiful as your
display allows right okay um all right
well should we wait a little bit for
Jeremy to come up with the next
iteration and it I - okay okay meanwhile
meanwhile what can i play with here by
the way for the next meeting about
generated variables I don't know whether
we already have the inventory of where
we're well hasn't that's coming up help
did I call this completely I'm trying -
oh there we go
only um you know is did we agree that
this is a bug down here that um so we
discussed that with Chris and I mean
it's the the bug is that that's not
respecting your auto height settings
which is a known issue and well well is
on the to do to-do list which Chris
settings right so you know your Mac OS
has auto height scrollbar settings which
defaults to automatically hide scroll
bars and it's not respecting that when
you write but yeah I mean the reason it
seems to not be doing anything I
realized after our conversation
yesterday was because you weren't in a
cell that was too wide right the further
the horizontal scroll only has an effect
when your cursor is inside a cell that's
so tell me it cool yeah I'm just I'm
just going to I just want to see some
things in the wild so to speak how do i
generate a good random polynomial okay
so
it's going to generate a bunch of those
oh it's interesting there are ones that
have more digits so you're doing
basically three digit precision here
except for these ones which aren't three
digit precision for some reason well
that's just right there that's just
number form okay right I mean it's that
one point dot dot dot minus whatever is
that an exact one point do you think it
made me wealthy then why is it saying
one point well because these are because
they're machine numbers now right so
[Music]
honestly I think it's it's you know
where the wrong way around here I think
the numbers should be slightly gray I
don't think there should be you know the
gray background kind of pops the numbers
out which is exactly the opposite of
what should be going on it's just like
there is a thing here it's I mean I do
like the fact that this is comparatively
let's just try a much even bigger case
of this sure you are looking at the
preview of the exact number wrapper
around everything so you see there there
is no no radical in front of it so so
that's the if you look at the input form
it's exact number of that okay okay
I'm just looking at cases of this okay
so I mean so the point is
don't have any tilde tilde than them and
I don't just we didn't design it for him
I mean we didn't design an icon so you
could pick it out yeah I understand why
exactly again do we need the tilde tilde
we wanted it to indicate we wanted to
tell you that this is an exact number
but it's printed as approximate right
okay so we've got two ways we can think
of to do that I mean we've got the
graying it out three ways the graying it
out the dot dot dot and the tilde tilde
and they don't know they're just growing
it out is enough it may help but I think
you need a just growing out doesn't tell
me oh this is actually an exact guy I
think you need either tilde tilde or or
ellipsis right okay we are we going to
get something here Jeremy I'm mailing
you right now okay
okay so what are we seeing here again I
think there's going to take them okay so
you have roundedrect s-- 102 variation
so the first ones a little bigger color
you can't see the blue very much but
it's the bigger version with color then
roundedrect of the same and then the
second sets a little smaller font size
of the numbers and a little grayer I
have a great desire to click that button
yeah
looks very similar to our Alpha logo or
symbol a little too much yeah
all right look I don't think we've quite
solved this yet I mean what I'm
suggesting is lose the gray background
right go gray with the numbers and lose
most of the gray background here I can
show you what it looks like one size
smaller if you want to see that yeah
I'll need to share okay zoom is giving
me the speech both Tim okay there it
goes
all right so this is all these have one
well this one's a special ignore that
one but all of these guys have one size
smaller and they've me and they've made
it just very slightly gray I can make it
more gray because I think that's great
make it more gray and I would lose the
background gray can you change the
background gray yes actually
okay so there's that's forcing a white
background I mean we could try making it
transparent or white it's fine I mean I
think white is fine I don't think
there's any reason to have greater okay
yeah actually I can actually kind of
like this I thought we needed the gray
but looking at this now okay now the
question is do we even need
you know do we need any icon there and
do we need the dot dot dots so the two
things that they were communicating up
until now was the icon said this is the
type of number it's it's a root thing
second the dot said this is this is
really an infinite number and you just
seeing initial segments of it yes
infinite precision I mean I don't know
that really communicates that that's the
problem okay so listen look I think this
is pretty decent
I think removing the icon having the dot
dots might be the best we can do okay
with a smaller size and so on
let's but let's give that to Jeremy you
guys can talk about it some more but
that would be my initial take okay all
right I think that's that for this
meeting and okay those who are on the
livestream we're actually going to go to
another meeting about a somewhat related
topic about generative variables in just
a moment here so if you will up on this
one and we will restart the next one so
hope to see all